hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby
and tonight we have another road to 2000
live stream
tournament uh it's very exciting this is
number four
i believe from what i'm told so
uh lots of fun you guys have just two
minutes to get into the tournament oh my
god
the time flies and i'm not totally
certain i have
the correct chat open anymore so let me
make sure i can pull that up and i'll
link you guys
straight to our team and once you join
the team
and then you can join the event but you
gotta go fast gotta go
fast so here i am in the chat room
posting the link to the tournament
um so i think it will prompt you to join
the team
if you are not part of the team just yet
and then you'll be able to join and play
right now only two players
not a massive tournament so get in here
you could be
the road 2000 live stream tournament
champion it could be you could be you
right here
right now otherwise it's going to be a
very
exciting match between uh pb
diamond it looks like and audreuth
number five
uh and one of those will be your
champion
if we don't get some more people in i
believe you are able
to join a little bit late so even if
round one
is just these two players we may get
more
as the tournament progresses virtuo dude
would join but needs to eat something
otherwise your brain just won't be there
what time does it start you have 30
seconds
virtuo dude 30 seconds probably like 10
seconds by the time you hear me
but uh yeah we got a little bit of a
late start had some issues but now we're
live and going oh and we have a third
player
a third player has entered the mix maybe
i should play
uh spice things up a little bit but no
no i can't i have to uh have to
commentate
so right now it's gonna be a massive
four-way battle with the ben simon
joining
and this will be a big chance oh five
players they're coming in
they're coming in quickly uh a rafale
gone all right let's
go ahead and take a look at ruffle guns
game here he's
up against is fish sushi
we also have ben simon playing against
pb
diamond all right one e4 by roflagan and
is fish sushi has is fish sushi responds
with e5 we have the
petrov defense d6 all right knight f394
and i recently recorded a video where
white goes nate c3
in black plays bishop f5 who can name
that game
in the chat knight c3 bishop f5 there's
two games you could uh potentially name
there but we don't see any of that today
we just get d4 and d5
instead and this is pretty tame stuff
both players have a
fairly symmetrical pawn structure
sometimes you'll see
white launch an early pawn out to c4
trying to take advantage of that
extra move to apply some pressure to the
center and we actually do see
we're offlogging going for that uh in
this position
so now we see black taking the more
defensive approach uh
c6 solidly defending the pawn on d5
whereas white with c4 and now the pawn
on c3
uh more attacking approach and so now
the question is going to be
whose pawn structure on the queen's side
is
worse we have this slightly weak pawn on
b6 but after c takes d5 white has
actually opened up
the c file for an attack on the c3 pawn
it actually furthermore opened up this
c6 square for the knight not sure if i
would have been
so quick to take on d5
by the way if you are just joining i
will post the link to the tournament one
more time
we are still short on players so please
please please feel free to join
and you could potentially be the road
2000 champion
uh this game well underway white seems
to know what they're doing going after
the b
pawn and keeping the pieces well
developed black
also doing perfectly fine though this is
the type of line that
is very much going to be a marginal
advantage
for white so not too much going on here
just yet let's check in on pb diamond
versus the ben simon and oh my god ben
simon's king
is on a5 what happened i gotta i gotta
back up
and see what happened i was the old
fried liver
i should have known should have known uh
and white actually won this piece back
right away
and now uh it's looking a little bit
tough for ben he's down a full piece
the king has found shelter but the fried
liver strikes again
might come would be shaking his head
um i think the tournament has been
abbreviated
to three rounds because that's how many
there would be for a round robin
with the number of players we started
with it might be a short stream here
today
we might have a winner uh before too
long
but let's see what happens in this game
with ben simon
and the king is just getting uh
shredded on f6 i don't want to look at
this anymore i don't want to look
anymore let's go back to this boring
game
where white is pressing with a small
advantage and yeah you see b6 by black
so not really a move you want to play as
black yes it puts your pawn on a square
where it's defended
but then you see this plan that white is
coming up with here of playing a4
potentially even a later a5 is really
going to put the pressure on to this
b-pawn
and yeah potentially black could solve
the weakness by capturing on
a5 but then you're letting this rook
into the game letting the fox into the
hen house
not always so good
hessham says you could not join um
i'm not totally sure on how chess.com
works with
late joins to these things but a
potential problem could be that you need
to join our
st louis chessclubchest.com team if you
are a part of that then it probably is
some late joint thing with chess.com
so here we see some tic tacs in this
game
and white does seem to be up upon at the
end of the day
solidifying this bishop on to d5 that
being said
this isn't exactly the ideal position
for white yes you have one upon
but now black has the rooks well
situated to target these guys
and with opposite colored bishops there
are some chances here
for black to uh to hold on to things
we shall see all right rookie one shack
the king is going to have to
pick a side either the center file or
the f file
it comes back to f8 even with only two
pieces on the board
black showing some caution keeping the
king out of
the pure center of the board and i think
that's a reasonable way to go
now though uh we are down to an opposite
colored bishop end game
and i'm going to stop looking at the
pieces i'm going to start looking at the
clocks
is fish sushi probably even if
this position is drawn not going to be
able to
hold this position for the sole reason
that uh you know they're down to 13
seconds here and with 13 seconds it's
just not
going to go very well for anybody
when did i start learning chess
seriously um it depends on what you mean
by seriously but
i did play my first tournament and start
really learning in about
fifth grade joined my school's chess
club had a good time
yeah his fish sushi now down to four
seconds
lost his piece and will lose the game
reasonably quickly here i would argue
within point one
oh yep okay there you go end of the game
and we also have this game wrapped up as
well
the king went all over the board it
touched the a file
it touched the h file and that is where
it was
lane to rest uh there to stay
all right round two is underway round
two of three it really will
be a quick stream today it looks like uh
maybe i'll play some games or something
after just to keep the fun going
um but let's keep an eye on our
top board here we've got adruth who is
the lower rated player in the event with
a first-round buy i believe
and one full point starting off so let's
see what address can do
against ralph lagann who is off to a
good start
in the meantime we do have pb diamond
who won their first game against ben
simon up against
abre brinius a british and this is
looking to be
another game with an open e file and a
reasonably symmetrical pawn structure in
fact
i would go as far as to say yes this was
also a pet shop the petrov defense
making a strong showing in today's
tournament
um and yeah already white is uh putting
on a little bit of pressure on pb
diamond here we have
the pin against the knight and also an
attack against the bishop on c5 looking
good
uh checking in on what i'm calling board
one here
we have andrew playing d4
uh and i think the tactics do work out
for
white here you are relying on this pin
to keep your pawn defended and we
actually see white
retreating this bishop now i wonder if
this pawn will be forgotten about i
do wonder uh bishop f5 by
black and yeah i have to say rofle gone
playing with a little bit of fire here
keeping the king
in the center for so long we do see uh a
single check by
andruth i wonder if it will turn into
more
will the single check turn into an
attack that being said i
just counted the pieces and black has
more of them
so that's probably more relevant than
anything else here and oh my goodness
g4 is on the board doesn't look ideal
for white this is
ambitious to say the least but maybe
there is a grand plan
in mind i believe
that white may have been hoping for
something like queen takes queen takes
knight takes and knight takes on d5 with
pressure here
and threats here but of course after
knight takes
um we are simply making a counter threat
of queen f2 to h2 with checkmate not
even a time
not even time to play knight takes d5
you're just gonna get slaughtered
and so we see f3 trying to keep the game
going but
definitely looking good for ralph lagann
back over here
it looks like this game is still well
underway
and white is trying to turn this slight
opening edge
into something more uh we saw this
knight come to e4
in this bishop on c5 now has gotten
kicked around the board
back to b6 we still see this nagging
pressure
against the knight on f6 and white is
definitely taking his time here
in no rush to capture on f6 and in fact
he's rewarded for this patience because
now we see h6 by pb diamond and that is
a free
pawn that's been captured
do i have tournament plans for myself
going for i am not
really uh not really at the moment
i'm still gonna be playing chess but i'm
not like actively looking to travel
around
to norm tournaments or anything uh and i
do have to get fm
before i think about i am so plenty left
to work on there
okay we do see a british and capturing
on f8
that is going to be an extra exchange to
go with the extra pawn
and oh my goodness one quick move
by pb diamond trying to press on the
clock but leaving this bishop behind
a4 a pretty nasty idea for white here
and that is going to be
uh one extra rook after this bishop is
captured
so white is a rook to the good but now
we
see uh pb diamond going all out trying
to force some mistakes
with the limited time that being said
let's check back in on rofl gone
how is it going for raffle gone um
definitely still a game roughly gone
down to 30 seconds oh and
as i say that you know commentators
curse we do see a hanging piece
so not not ideal for white but
30 seconds on the clock there are many
many things that could happen but
again things do seem to be deteriorating
here
for uh adruth and we see a trade
not necessarily what you want if you're
playing with the white pieces here you
want to keep some pieces on
so you can keep the pressure on the
clock but white
now has traded off the final piece and
i you know 20 seconds isn't a lot but
i think gone is probably going to be
able to pull this one out here there's
just too much
stuff left on the board and we do see
the pawn
beginning the march to the end and that
will be the end of the game once this
queen's on the board
14 seconds is plenty of time to find
checkmate unless this king
can show some dance moves yeah king g8
that's the thing to do with white here
you don't want to capture too many
pieces you want to use the enemy pieces
to
hide a little bit seven seconds uh but
that
is checkmate not yet though not yet okay
we see the queen
and mate with five seconds to spare
aprenius
also pulling out his game against pb
diamond
and what do we have now and the last
round
is underway there's just one person on
two out of two and that is roth lagann
up against aprenius definitely this is
the game
to be watching uh what else do we have
we have mendel
in the tournament who i have not seen
playing yet
up against pb diamond
uh but let's keep an eye on this we have
our roy lopez
and bishop a4 knight f6 okay pretty
normal stuff
just the classical roy closed roy that
is
we get b5 bishop b3 and let's see what
line
the players are going to go for we get
castles
and c3 by white will it be a marshall
gambit
will we see a marshall in this game by
bernius
or will we see d6 ah just d6
vibranius no marshall gambit today get
d6 knight a5
and c5 and the the classical roy
at its finest d4 by
white and black now steps back to
pressure that pawn
and we're seeing the knight retreat back
to b8 here
alright so with the center fully closed
now it'll be interesting to see
where the players decide to focus their
attack
a lot of the time you'll see these
knights route themselves out
to f5 but with the center so closed i
wonder if black will be able to
find some counter play on the queen side
what variation of the roy lopez is this
i am not the right guy to be asking
these questions i definitely should know
the name of this one but uh
i couldn't tell you off the top of my
head i just know it as like the
classical roy this is
the way they played it in the olden days
before they realized that the marshall
gave it was so good
i think that's uh my chest history
knowledge at least
all right we get b4 by white and this is
a pretty committal move now i'm not
sure if i'm actually such a big fan of
this
okay c takes b is interesting i was
wondering
maybe you could consider just retreating
the knights
with the idea of playing a5 and a takes
b4 and
opening up the a file this though is
potentially also a good
idea because you don't necessarily have
to remove this knight from
c5 just yet you can keep this piece here
for a little bit longer
and oh that's didn't want to guess the
move
and potentially you know still have
ideas on the queen's site don't want to
give too much away
as bernius is thinking let's check back
in on mendel though who
is uh also a higher rated player in the
tournament
and mendel is just shredding pb diamond
is this another like
fred liver or something no it was
this stuff how did this king get so out
in the open
king e7 here is bold generally
when you hang a g7 pawn like this you
want to play just rook f8 you keep the
king there you play rook f8 where it's
defended
who cares about the h7 pawn and you
castle queen's side
otherwise you get checkmated in like 15
moves exactly like this
so we see more wild king hunts out of
the opening
players not respecting the king's safety
today and mendel moves to two out of
three
so ralph lagann is going to have to at
least
draw this game to secure clear first
place
i'm not entirely certain how the tie
breaks are going to work out
on chess.com i get the feeling ralph
lagann might be winning on tiebreaks
anyways
but definitely it would be nice for him
to
actually win it outright rather than
you know rely on those tiebreaks hello
pablo lopez
uh okay rook c8 played and we see black
uh actually yes maneuvering this knight
back in order to allow his pieces access
to the c3 weakness not the plan i had
actually come up with i thought black
was gonna go for a5 a4
and rather than focus on targeting the c
the c3 pawn i thought black was just
going to try to invade
on the a file and activate the pieces
like this
um that being said it's hard to disagree
with what black has done here because
black is attacking a weakness and white
is seemingly without a plan generally
white wants to rely
on this bishop being a little bit out of
play and hard to activate
but i'm not seeing an effective plan for
white here and after f3
you know i really do have to say i like
black's position quite a bit b4 i think
is a great move because now you ensure
your bishop is going to be active i'm
looking bishop a6 rook c5 a4 ideas
and all your pieces are going to come
flooding into the game here and yeah
bishop a6 and a4 by ibranius he finds
the same idea
you know sans the rook c5 and now
black's pieces are simply able
to activate along this b file
it doesn't really matter that we didn't
win the c3 pawn all we needed to do
is activate our pieces now rook a7
though and i'm not such a huge fan
of this idea you know the huge advantage
for black was being on the c
file first as the only open file on the
board
and black gives up that advantage and
then gives up a rook
as well missing the sneaky bishop on d1
defending this pawn on the a4 and that's
going to happen
in these lower time control games 19
seconds on the clock
and abrinius just throws in the towel
decides not to play this one out and try
to go for the flag
and with that it is the fastest
road to 2000 tournament of all time
unfortunately we did have
some tech issues at the very start and
we didn't have a lot of time
for people to join the event and so it
ends after just three rounds that being
said
rothlagon is the champion tonight
and if you do want to
send mike an email i believe there's an
email
listed on the tournament page
on our website you are eligible
to be entered into a uh
raffle for a gm lesson that's the grand
prize you could potentially get
a free lesson with the resident
grandmaster so congratulations
to raffle gone be sure to reach out uh
you could even reach out on chess.com i
believe to the st louis chess club
account
and we'll get you entered into that
chance for a gm lesson uh
that being said i think we're gonna call
it here today a little bit early
um still a fun event even though it was
a bit smaller than normal i
as always i enjoy commentating on these
things hopefully you guys
at home enjoy it as well a little bit of
a strange setup today
we're in uh one of the famed chess
houses in the st
louis chess club but uh we're making it
work all right thank you everybody
for watching as always my name is caleb
denby
and i will see you next time goodbye
you